oh it's with the cast I sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off
leave the guy alone all right huddle up
everybody bring it in bring it so he
wouldn't say what happened which can
only mean one thing he's in a Fight Club
no he did it doing something he's
embarrassed by like smiling only
question is how do you hurt your arm
smiling could be a sports injury I
sprained my wrist in college playing
field hockey
Bin's field hockey yeah it's much more
violent than the women's game we're not
allowed to wear anything that protects
our breasts attention everyone I can
hear you speculating about the nature
and origin of my injury from my office I
tripped over an uneven sidewalk I did
not think it was relevant to your jobs
the jobs which you should all be doing
right now get to work do you want to
know how I actually heard - yes I was
looking Kevin and I attend a class for
fitness and for fun oh my god I've
mastered all the moves the pizza toss
the tornado the Scorpion the oopsie
doodle why are you telling me this
because no one will ever believe you
know
both are you leading an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra pepper Gina
smart Jimmy you need to watch yourself
I'm sorry cop all right
let's everybody just stay calm here Oh
what are you gonna arrest me for dancing
you call that dancing this is dancing
what is happening dancing over situation
confused many people think that
scrambled eggs are the easiest food to
make that is incredibly foolish they are
a highly nuanced and complicated dish
okay
now go ahead and pour your eggs right
into the pan nice and slow oh okay now
what do I do
oh boy hey we hear that sizzle that
means the heat is a little too high on
those eggs well the higher the heat the
faster the eggs cook the sooner Kevin
eats and correct no you make an
excellent point but we don't want to
feed Kevin burned garbage cooking it's
about patience are you completely insane
you never
saltcan a pen it's a hand the hand is
the middleman okay what you did is the
culinary equivalent of unprotected sex
you know what you sir are not ready to
scramble eggs hand over your spatula
fine I only wish in return I could get
back all the time I just wasted on this
futile project I'm just gonna make Kevin
plain toast for breakfast oh that is low
well I smell bernie is Hitchcock
roasting corn on the radiator again know
what she smells the burning wreckage of
my relationship with holt
good morning Boyle Oh
good morning Kevin Oh after our
disagreement yesterday I went online to
read your culinary blogs and scoff to my
dismay I actually learned something
about how food tells a story so I made
Kevin this it's warm it's a croque
monsieur Kevin and I shared one on a
rainy afternoon in Paris on our first
anniversary it's one of our most
treasured memories I'm sure it's not up
to your standards but Kevin seemed to
enjoy it so thank you for your guidance
hmm gross huh no it's perfect
he's a natural ship now I know how
Salieri Jake the overwhelming time
pressure yep
all right Isaac seventy account book was
in room two sticks by it's gotta be
upstairs hey were you going to the dance
contest
I am nationally-recognized foxtrot err
Dave play this and these are my proteges
rhonda shawarma and hank frankel I don't
care who you are
upstairs is close to the public bye but
we didn't have to endure this crap when
we danced in barthelona
the hearings starting any seconds there
may be another staircase on the dance
floor I'll sign us up for the contest
it's a good idea
oh and Amy your dress makes you look
like a mermaid okay I see a little bit
we should try to blend in stretch your
leg up of your head stretch your leg up
over your head you think I wouldn't if I
could oh that's like the captain kind of
partner okay we begin with the three -
period - the spicy sounds of Omar all
right
the linoleum awaits my dear
[Music]
I know undercover but I'm starting to
get real nervous about this contest you
need to see a therapist it stands this
way how did you manage to step on both
of my feet at the same time I'm horrible
at this one can we stop I'm horrible at
this no I know
title of my sex tape yeah well done
title of my sex tape oh my god captain
could believe in this thing how did you
get so amazing at dancing take a focus I
found a back stairway over here
and spin captain allow me to introduce
you to major East Coast arms dealer Dan
Daniel Valdano that's right his nickname
is longer than his actual name why is
that Terry cuz he's a dig we got a
warrant to bug him but his house is a
fortress and he never goes anywhere in
public but luckily see I just gave us a
break
Bob Donald's gonna actually leave his
house to go to a high-stakes poker game
this Friday if we can get a seat at that
table we could lose them this watch to
him and guess what he's blond
yes it's but good guess captain plan is
we go to the club tonight show off our
poker skills and get an invite to the
high-stakes game all we need is $15,000
to get in the door it's a lot of money
are you Booker skills good good perhaps
I should see for myself
how do you play I am I damn cab are you
secretly cool well poker is just math so
I guess it depends on if you consider
the mathematician Carl Friedrich Gauss
cool I do not I win again which is not
surprising given how you're both
terrible you don't even know the
terminology what are you talking about
hit me that is blackjack snake eyes
craps Go Fish and I believe that is go
fish fine Jake stinks but I can play yes
but you have a rather unfortunate
tell your right breast oh no my cars are
terrible sure they are damn it Eugene
you sold me out captain
do I ever tell no you don't understand
the game well enough to have a tell yeah
that makes sense what about you what's
your tell it is subtle
you will never desert it oh really well
challenge accepted
tell me a lie you both grated poker and
I'm not gonna cancel this mission you
know I couldn't see it and now you're
going to fold fold fold fold fold fold
should we consider cutting our losses
hush sergeant our cards are coming and
there is what I won you won one again
that's our straight and again again ah
damn for all to see damn damn now you
see it full house paints over threes
good now say to the dealer yeah this has
been fun but I'm sick of playing with
little little babies is there a table
for people who wear big-boy pants
attention squad quick announcement
overtime is reinstated and you are each
allowed to personal photographs two
trinkets and three assorted knickknacks
you know what just follow sergeant
Jeffords lead he always knows how to
keep this place running smoothly nice so
rubberband balls are back oh no it's bad
for the bands Oh Kevin let me just get
my coat
hello Peralta Gina oh sweet Lord dance
thank you we're back on a first-name
basis Kevin I am unable and unwilling to
discuss personal matters with you I'm
aware of that yes in any case thank you
for your help
I brought you both gifts original
Raymond Holts I will treasure this
painting of Iraq for all times rock 59
and 367 those are good rocks 367
paintings of one rock this guy party
you